did you know that most men think of the
Roman Empire every single day now I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
there is no way that my spouse thinks
about the Roman Empire daily
I asked my husband last night in jest
and do you know what this man said he
said well in some capacity probably
every day why
so when I saw the meme go around
I thought to myself because I wasn't
conscious of the fact that I think of
the Roman Empire every day but I do the
minute I saw it I said oh yeah I guess I
do what do do women not think of the
Roman Empire every day and then I was
sitting at home in sweet little Elisa
turned to me she goes mag she saw the
meme she was Mac
do you do you really think of the Roman
Empire every day I thought girl I
you live with me I basically talk about
the Roman Empire every day